sous le régime impérial du chah l'iran
était une société laïque et ouverte sur
le monde
mais sa dérive autoritaire a donné des
munitions au conservatisme religieux
en 1979 le régime est donc renversée et
c'est l'ayatollah khomeini revenu d'exil
qui conduit le pays vers une république
islamique
et dès son arrivée les relations avec
les états unis désormais étiqueté le
grand satan ont complètement basculé
surtout lorsque le 4 novembre
l'ambassade américaine est prise
d'assaut et 52 diplomates sont retenus
en otage en collaboration avec la cia et
le canada interviendra dans une
opération d'exfiltration de six
diplomates
il faudra attendre 444 jours avant la
libération de tous les otages sous la
présidence de rügen une véritable
humiliation pour les états unis la
question diplomatique avec l'iran sera
d'autant plus grande lorsque les
etats-unis fourniront des armes au
régime de saddam hussein dans le conflit
iran irak durera de 1980 à 1988 et le
fait que les américains abattront par
erreur un avion commercial iranien en
juillet 88 faisant 290 morts dont 66
enfants ne fera qu'attiser la haine du
pays sous george w bush l'iran fera
désormais partie de l' axe du mal avec
l'irak et la corée du nord depuis 1980
les relations diplomatiques sont donc
officiellement rompu entre l'iran et les
états unis
mais ce qui inquiète surtout l'occident
c'est la menace nucléaire de l'iran qui
prend forme en 2011 avec ses capacité
d'enrichir l'uranium pour fabriquer une
bombe atomique
avec l'élection du président roi ni
barack obama tentera un rapprochement en
2013 d'un grand première au niveau
diplomatique
un changement de ton qui mènera à la
conclusion d'un accord international sur
le programme nucléaire iranien le 24
novembre un réchauffement des relations
qui permet de réduire la menace
nucléaire dans la région
mais dès son élection donald trump
balaye tous ses efforts il se retire
unilatéralement de l'accord suscitant la
désapprobation internationale il impose
même de lourdes sanctions économiques à
l'iran un retour à la case départ et des
tensions qui refont surface lors d'une
attaque contre deux pétroliers dans le
détroit d'ormuz en juin 2019 accuse en
iran le président trump enverra un
millier de soldats américains dans la
région auxquels s'ajouteront trois mille
cinq cents autres depuis l'escaladé du
début de 2020 et les tensions avec le
canada dans tout ça
ce sera entre autres la sphère art
academy qui jettera un froid avec ottawa
la photographe iranienne résidant à
montréal était arrêté en juin 2003
devant la prison d'evin à téhéran alors
qu'elle prenait des clichés de
manifestants emprisonnés et torturés
elle mourra à moins de trois semaines
plus tard les relations diplomatiques
entre le canada et la reine ont été
suspendus en 2012 le gouvernement
canadien fermera son ambassade basé à
téhéran coupera les liens diplomatiques
avec la république islamique et imposera
de nouvelles sanctions économiques ici
frédéric arnould radio canada montréal